Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
It's great to welcome to the program today,
Travis reader who is a faculty member at the
Johns Hopkins Berman Institute of Bioethics.
And also often
there are of the book in pain, a bioethicist
personal struggle with opioids, a Travis,
so great to talk to you today.
Thanks for having me on, David.
Really appreciate this.
So maybe just to get started, so, so the audience
can understand your personal background and
the connection to opioids.
Talk to us, uh, generally about the motorcycle
accident you were in the surgeries and sort
of the path into opioids.
Yeah, it was, um, it was not a great year.
2015 I went out for a motorcycle ride on Memorial
Day weekend and I didn't make it three blocks
from home before a van, a side, sorry, before
a van t-boned me and crushed my foot between
the bumper and the motorcycle.
Um, so the injury that resulted was really
severe.
I was in what's called a limb salvage situation,
so that meant that my foot was at threat of
amputation and the severity of that sort of
injury me is that, um, I had a lot of surgeries
to look forward to.
I was going to be hospitalized for weeks or
months.
And so the result of that is that I was on
a lot of pain medication, uh, for quite a
long time and thanks to the tolerance that
opioids built up.
Um, I was on escalating doses of pain medication
for about two months total.
And before that in your life, had you been
on opiate painkillers?
Not that I can recall.
You know, maybe at some point when I was younger
I had a nasty broken bone from sports and
got Vicodin and probably wasn't even given
it by my parents.
Um, I was considered opiate naive by the physician,
so I'd certainly not been on the pills for
three or six months prior and maybe had never
been.
And when you were put on the drugs, was it
one particular drug the entire time or were
they, were there different ones?
Lots of different ones.
Uh, so for this sort of accident I was a trauma
case, you know, you tend to get passed through
systems and so on the ambulance I'd get intravenous
morphine.
Um, when it got to the hospital they switched
that to fentanyl.
Um, eventually, uh, my IB drug of choice,
not mine, but at the hospitals, uh, was hydromorphone
brand named allotted.
Um, but then to kind of build up something
that I could take home, cause IB medicine
is not something that you typically can take
home.
I was put on oxycodone and I comes in both
the immediate release form.
So just normal oxycodon that goes into your
system as quick as oral medicines can.
And then extended release oxycodone, which
most people know and are the brand name Oxycontin.
So at what point in this or is there a point
or how early, is there a discussion about
their risk with these drugs?
You need to careful, we need to be careful
or did that not come up until you realize
that there was a problem?
Yeah, it never came up.
I mean this is probably the most shocking
feature of my entire story is, you know, I
had this two month period where I was on high
and escalating doses of opioids and I was
in three different world-class hospitals on
the eastern seaboard.
I had, you know, 10, 12, maybe more clinicians
who signed their name to a prescription for
these medications.
I was seen by dozens of doctors and nurses
coming through and not a single person ever
said anything to me about, um, the formation
of dependence, which means that, you know,
I'll withdrawal if I'm taking, if the medication
is taken away.
Nobody talked about the risk of addiction.
Uh, the only cost of these medications that
was ever raised was constipation.
Everybody was very worried about constipation.
But, uh, that was it.
And what about as you talk about as you develop
a tolerance, you're on escalating, you know,
amounts of the active ingredients.
Even at that point there was not a discussion
about, okay, these doses are starting to get
quite high now.
No, and as a matter of fact, the only real
advice I got about pain regarding medication
was you have to stay ahead of the pain.
A couple times early on I got behind the pain,
they say, and it's just excruciating.
You really feel like you're going to die.
Sometimes you hope you're going to die.
The pain is just all consuming.
And so they say, look, don't risk getting
behind the pain.
Make sure you take the medication before you're
in that situation.
And so, you know, I thought I was being a
good soldier.
I was following doctor's orders and every
four hours, you know, I popped the next oxycodone
pill every 12 hours I popped the next oxycontin
pill.
And if I felt it wearing off even a little
bit, I'd call a prescribing doc, say, hey,
my tolerance is going up.
And he'd say, okay, let's bump it from 15
to 20 milligrams or whatever.
So at what point did you realize that you
were starting to have a problem?
I never did.
Um, I went to a trauma surgeon, follow up
appointments and, uh, so he's a guy I hadn't
seen and, and weeks, uh, he, you know, initially
pulled the bones in my foot back together
and then passed me off to other teams to fix
the rest of the foot.
And, uh, he just kind of going through his
checklist and sees the doses I'm on and gets
very stern, very concerned, and says, you
know, these doses are far too high.
You're two months out, you've got to get off
the meds now.
Um, but he didn't offer any advice.
You know, it's kind of like, you've got to
get off, but that's not my problem.
I haven't been controlling this train.
Um, so he sent me to the plastic surgeon who
had been writing the most recent prescriptions.
And what did, what happened at that point?
Well, the plastic surgeon was much less concerned
and he also, um, just clearly didn't know
what he was doing.
You know, he, he would admit that much later
to me, he would apologize, but, um, he just
hadn't dealt with dependence before.
And so he was like, Oh yeah, um, you have
to taper the pills.
Uh, so let's divide your daily dose into four,
drop a quarter each week, and you'll be off
the medication in a month.
And did that, I mean, when you were told that
number one, did you understand like the importance
and urgency of it?
And number two was that was that practical
advice that you could actually follow?
So I think my partner Saudia, I think she
was skeptical.
Yes.
She's a research scientist by training and
she asked some follow up questions.
I didn't know anything.
You know, I was still fairly traumatized and
out of it.
Um, so I was like, yeah, you know, this is
the plan.
Um, but no, it's, it's terrible advice.
Um, so what I would find out much, much later
turns out more than a year later in my own
research, is that you practically never should
start tapering a dependent patient at faster
than a 10% dose reduction per week.
And then some patients will be able to go
faster if they haven't been on for very long,
and some patients will need to go much, much
slower because the withdrawal will be so severe.
And in my case, the withdrawal was very severe.
And so as soon as I dropped that first dose,
these medications that were really short,
half life.
So on the first day that you drop a significant
dose, if you're dependent, you'll feel withdrawal
and it's excruciating.
Was there a point at which you did not need
the doses you were on for the amount of pain
you were experiencing, but started to recognize
that there were other reasons why you were
inclined to take the medication?
That's a really good and really hard question.
You know, it kind of requires me to be a mind
reader of my distant past health.
Yeah.
I kind of feel like the answer must be yes.
Um, I was so concerned to stay ahead of the
pain and I was scared of what I had experienced
in the past.
And so I did a lot of clock watching and I
did a lot of, you know, early medicating.
Um, I was not chasing euphoria.
That was not something that happened to me,
at least not yet.
And so I don't think I was, you know, kind
of as far down the path towards addictive
behavior as um, as you can certainly get.
But I was, I was almost certainly medicating
more than I should have been more than I needed
to.
And so what I knew to only much, much later,
and what I know now is that very few people
should be on that high dose for that long.
Um, because the opioids are going to cause
profound dependence.
That's just the way they work.
Uh, and they tend to not work very well as
analgesics, as pain medication and the long
term.
And so likely what I should have done is starting
in the first couple of weeks out of the hospital,
I should have been as aggressively as possible
titrating down the dose and putting up with
the most pain possible.
Um, and I was just in no place to do that.
No one, no one told me that.
So
how bad, like what would you say was the peak
of, of the problem ultimately in terms of,
of, of dependence and then what did actually
ultimately work to start reducing the doses
properly?
Yeah.
Um,
so the sick joke of opioid tapering is that
it gets worse the farther along you get because
if you're dropping by a set reduction each
week or each two weeks, um, then the more
you drop the higher percentage dose reduction.
That is kind of complicated.
Right?
But yeah, first week it was only a quarter.
The second week it was a third.
The third week it was half and then the fourth
week you drop all the rest.
Right.
And so the severity of withdrawal is relative
to that percentage dose reduction.
And so every week got workers and it was in
the fourth week, um, that, you know, I hadn't
slept well and weeks and I hadn't slept at
all in days because withdrawal is the opposite
of the drug's effects.
And so opioids to date you withdrawal keeps
you kind of jittery and hyper alert and say,
I felt like I had to kind of fire inside me.
And I was incredibly depressed because the
opposite of euphoria which you get with opioids
is dysphoria.
And I cried all the time and I thought I was
profoundly broken.
And in that fourth week I was, I was convinced
from the inside that I was going to die from
withdrawal and you could not have convinced
me otherwise.
I thought that I had special access to just
help broken.
I was and I was pretty sure I wasn't going
to survive it.
And once you got two and pass that fourth
week, what happened?
Well,
so basically, you know, the second part of
your earlier question was what worked and,
and nothing worked.
I just, um, I was incredibly fortunate that
I had a really strong support system, namely
my partner Saudia.
I had a one and a half year old daughter at
home seen CNM.
Um, and I tell a story about her in the book
where she kind of unwittingly probably she's
one and a half years old, but she comforts
me in a particular moment where, where I'm
at this cost, where I really think I'm not
going to survive this and what, what haunts
me for the month after I finally make it out
of this is I am quite sure that I would not
have made it out if I hadn't so desperately
wanted to be a good husband again to be a
good father to get this life back.
Right.
And so what happens to everybody else who
doesn't have that support system, who doesn't
have a bunch of things in their life that
they're desperately looking forward to?
It would've been so easy to medicate away
the suffering, especially because doctors
were telling me it was okay to do that.
They were like, oh, we can't offer you any
advice.
Just go back on the pills if it's that bad.
Yeah.
I think this is what's often missing from
the understanding of a in people who have
not experienced this personally, which is,
it's very easy to just say, I don't know,
it just sounds like I could taper and then
switch to a bunch of Advil and then taper
the Advil and it just, it's hard to imagine
when you hear the stories that don't go the
way yours went.
But rather it goes to, you know, by, I couldn't
get the prescriptions.
Buying the pills on the street was too expensive.
So I ended up with heroin.
It seems inconceivable to people who have
not actually ever had this medication.
But the line between your path and that path
seems to be relatively a, a small margin is
what I'm hearing from you.
It's razor thin.
You're so, so right.
Like that's the central insight here.
And whenever anybody says to me, you know,
you are so strong, congratulations.
I'm like coasting strong.
I was, I was a complete nerd.
I thought I was gonna die at every moment.
I was dragged across the finish line by my
family.
And by the way, at the end of that story,
I did give up.
I refilled a prescription because I couldn't
take it anymore.
And just by luck, that was the night I fell
asleep without taking any more pills.
And that, that sleep kind of pulled me back
together.
And after I thought I can finish detoxing,
but I was ready to go back.
And what I had said to Saudia is if I go back
on the meds, I will never come off them because
I will never be able to do this to myself
again.
And we both knew that we knew that that was
my commitment and that was my belief and we
decided to go back on them anyway.
So yeah, like it sounds crazy.
I'm a faculty member at Johns Hopkins.
Um, I have all of this kind of access and
privilege that not everybody has.
And I can tell you right now, if I had gone
back on the pills, which I was so close to
doing, and then I'd been cut off, I would
have been willing to buy them on the street.
Boy,
it's a, it's, it's, that's a, that's an incredible
thing that I think a lot of people just don't
understand until they're in it.
And that's why this is so pernicious.
And, and I, I don't know if you think it's
gotten, this was 2015 I don't know how much
you know about whether protocols have improved
since then, but this clearly is still a major
problem.
It's a huge problem.
Uh, I work with a lot of hospitals and healthcare
systems now and I, I speak at conferences
and advise organizations, and what I can say
is that the best ones are at least asking
for this help.
And part of why I wrote the book, you know,
I want everyone to read it.
I'm thrilled that you read it.
I'd be thrilled if everybody who thinks they
might be a pain patient someday, which is
all of us right, reads it.
But one of my great ambitions is I hope every
doctor feels like they need to know this.
Right.
And, um, I don't think it's gotten there yet.
I, I know the institutions, the really good
ones that have resources that are putting
them towards this problem, but I don't think
most places have figured this out yet.
And there's still this deeply fractured system
where clinicians are totally comfortable writing
a prescription that they do not have the knowledge
or willingness to then see through.
They don't know how to taper patients off
of it.
They don't know how to manage it longterm.
And that's the problem.
Yeah, it's a, it's, it's stunning that that's
the situation.
The book is fascinating.
It's called in pane a bioethics.
This is personal struggle with opioids.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Travis Reader, a Travis, really appreciate
your time today.
Absolutely.
Thanks for having me on David